so  [Music]  how's she doing she barely speaks to me  i don't need your sympathy uncle john  that mustang's got a real mean streak  she's just angry  she was rounded up and taken away from  her family  what's her name i haven't given her a  name yet  [Music]  i heard you lost your family too  you really are beautiful  that's what i'll call you black beauty  you've gotten closer to that philly in  days than i have in weeks  they say horses pick you thank you  rescues have a time limit you can't sell  me  you're my family you know that right  [Music]  she saved my life you know how can a  horse save a person  [Music]  if i fought for every horse i'd ever  loved  out of a hundred of them i don't want a  hundred horses  i just want one  you